e
e e
[Music]
good evening uh I'm convening the August
12 2024 finan committee meeting to order
the first item we have is temporary
resolution
8424 which is a resolution to increase
decrease Appropriations in the police
and fire Levy fund
247 for Lancaster fire department over
time this is coming from the Safety
Committee and councilman FJ yes uh thank
you chair wolfinger just want to share
that Mr aers will be my second on this
legislation um and it's just essentially
moving already encumbered funds from One
Fund already to the lanter fire
department overtime fund but I don't
want to take too much of Chief Ma and
thunder away from here so with that
little preview I'll turn it over to you
Chief um that's the gist of it I just I
need to move money into overtime um
we've had a lot of people off long term
this year that I wasn't anticipating
when I wrote the budget for this year
and we've had multiple people between
BWC injury leave and some FMLA uh that's
probably the biggest reasons you know
that's created it's not a shortfall yet
but I'm trying to get ahead of the game
uh considering that it's special event
season and all of those events that we
cover is also uh paid out of our
overtime fund so just wanted to move it
before we get anywhere close to Red
numbers and and as stated before just
want to emphasize these are not new
funds just to make that abundantly clear
so that's all and go ahead yeah can you
tell us which fund you're taking it out
of to move over uh buildings and grounds
is there a
different fund you could take that out
of instead of that we just
there's I don't want to say we have
plenty in there but compared to some of
the others where once we get closer to
the end of the year we start you know
moving money between the actual fund
numbers uh buildings and grounds right
now is the is the least likely that to
end up with a lot of other moves towards
the end of the year Well the reason I
was wondering because I know you you
know with the other thing moving on with
the maintenance and this and that of the
buildings and that I didn't know that
you would take it out of that particular
fund for overtime yeah we're we're still
covered we haven't there hasn't been a
lot of other projects that's had to come
out of there this year so um you know
we're
still covered for you know the building
project especially since it's going to
be at this point it's going to be next
year before we're actually moving
forward
with writing the check for that and
you'll be getting that money back into
that fund
when to replace that not going to do it
well it'll be carryover um so it'll
it'll still be available and we'll just
put it right back in that same line item
for when we write next year's
budget okay U Tom you're looking at can
you explain I know you've been on
Council I'm just wondering your
expertise in any of this with can you
say anything
if you're asking my opinion yes um um
well they're they're they're moving
money from from one thing to another but
the last comment kind of has me miffed
where we'll just build it back up next
year and then do this all over again
next year so how many how many uniform
firefighters do we have 83 83 and we're
dipping into over time so I understand
you have you mentioned you had some FMLA
and and uh perhaps some uh workers type
situations but when I hear you say
something to the effect of well we'll
just replenish it and put it back there
and then next year we'll have $100,000
sitting in building buildings and
grounds that we can move for overtime
that's bad that's bad process that's bad
policy that's a bad that's a bad thing
to say because what you're saying really
is we didn't really need this big bucket
of 100 grand for maintenance and grounds
that's my opinion well we yes thank you
that's why I wanted your opinion we had
budgeted for a building project for this
year year and we fully anticipated that
that project would be complete by late
fall and because of
various roadblocks along the way just
stuff that slowed the project down it's
going to be first of the year before we
can get that project done so how much
money was in that line
item I don't have the budget with me but
I'm I'm going to guess we started at
450,000 okay so then so this 100,000
will just take you to the end of the
year
for
overtime absolutely okay perfect thank
you
B may or Carrie is that okay well he I
just wanted to get your
attention something that uh Chief also
if I could just add on is he did budget
lower for overtime this year versus past
years because we were getting up to full
staff so he did not anticipate this the
problem is when we started budgeting for
full staff at the time we didn't realize
that some of the new hires wouldn't be
all the way through school so again
that's kind of added to the overtime as
well but now he's getting them all
completely out of the academy and
actually able to work in the medic
trucks and on the fire trucks so I think
that that is why again since he budgeted
lower that also contributed to needing
to move some of this money if I'm not
mistaken yeah my my
overtime budget for 2024 was almost 14%
less than what I had asked for in 2023
because I anticipated being a full staff
and and not having these issues but um
we've had as safety service director
mentioned um there's a little bit of a
challenge with a couple people in school
and they're having to be off even though
we tried to schedule them that they're
not doing medic school activities on
their Duty day when they're supposed to
be on a truck uh there're just some
aspects of of their classroom time that
that they have to go and it can't be
helped so that's a contributing factor
and you know prob honestly the the
biggest has been the number of people
we've had off for various reasons of f
FMLA onl Duty and the BWC injury leave
has has been our biggest challenges this
year just I'm just asking if you have
somebody on light duty did you bring
them in to work to do things answer
phones just to bring okay so you do
bring them in if they're light duty okay
so Bob at would like to add to that also
to speak to Tom's point I it is not the
practice to put money in building
maintenance or building um and grounds
to use it for overtime it was a
situation that hit us this year which is
isolated and I don't think that's what
the chief was trying to say when he said
he's going to he's talking about
rebuilding the building and maintenance
and grounds fund to pay for the new
building that we're building for
maintenance of Fire Equipment cuz
currently our firefighters year round
service their vehicles sometimes outside
in the snow so we're trying to address
that issue and the money he's talking
about re rebuilding into that fund is
specifically to fund that building to
get our firefighters inside covered and
our apparatus inside and
covered is that right Chief yes that's
exactly right I'm I'm sorry I'm not I
apparently a that was your concern I I
didn't understand no my concern is is we
have that much money sitting inactive in
an account that we can go draw from and
so I there were and then you said well
I'll just go build that because she she
had asked you how you going to get the
money back in there and you said well
next year we'll just ramp it back up
well what prevents you from doing this
again next year right but the other
answer the other question that you did
answer that had a good answer was well
do you believe you'll be coming back
again for another uh Tron of money for
uh overtime and you said no this ought
to do it for the end of the year that's
just just my points I mean those are the
if I was sitting in that chair down
there same questions that I would ask
you Becky asked me my opinion and I just
I'm just giving it to you I think the
critical difference in 2025 versus 2024
is we'll have 84 firefighters that are
fully certified uh as paramedics and
firefighters and this year we didn't
have that was not the case uh uh a
significant number we're working towards
our paramedic certification and can't
ride on and one of our Medics because
they're not certified so that required
overtime in some cases to staff that
medic so that we could run for Medics
which we promised to the community that
we would run so that's the difference
between 2024 and 2025 I a quick
different question and probably to both
of you more than anything we used to
only hire firefighter paramedics and I
know that we didn't what we're doing
this time is we're hiring firefighter
paramedics we we we're fixing that well
yeah I understand the reason you had you
couldn't hire people
uh I don't think you got to the point
where you didn't have enough really
qualified candidates so you really
couldn't backfill anybody is that
situation getting better it is much
better we went from you know when we
started hiring 2021 we needed we had 20
open positions essentially and now we're
we've got we have most of those filled
and we're we just need to hire one or
two at a time in fact our our one
opening right now is because of a a June
retirement um we anticipate perhaps one
more retirement and endend of this month
or maybe next month so we can we get a
smaller pool of candidates when we
require all the certifications upfront
rather than you know offering or paying
for people to go to school and right now
we have that
smaller pool of candidates but I think
it works well because when we only need
to hire one or two we don't have a list
of 50 people that is going to be good
for a year and then in 10 months we get
to call number 45 through 50 and they
all say either they say I have a job no
thank you or um I don't have a job I'll
be in and then you have to wonder why
and it just it's I think this process is
going to be more efficient of you know
filling our open positions the only
question I would ask just to follow up I
got my budget hat on sorry about this so
how many so of what your your your your
full strength is like 84 is that the
number so assuming you get there by the
end of this year how many of those 84
won't be firefighter paramedics and then
because that puts us in this potential
for next year that you know if you under
if you under you know budgeted your
overtime line item for this year that
you might think about maybe a different
number for next year oh I'm definitely
going to think about a different number
for next year but the question is is how
many how many people are not firefighter
paramedics so everybody's a firefighter
and right now we're down to three that
are not paramedics um two of them are
halfway through school one's just
started uh but everybody that's on our
our candidate list have to be Medics
before they can even take the test well
that's bad that's good and I'm glad it's
not like a double digit number right so
that's that could create a problem so
all right cool thanks for allowing me to
ask some questions I appreciate
that uh just to
reaffirm we passed legislation couple
months ago to buy land next to uh engine
house number three and the plan was to
have that building built and there was
money put in the budget to build that
building and this is the fund that took
away extra money would have been carried
over to the following year and I think
that's where your your confusion was so
it's not taking Robert to pay Paul there
was a dedicated source for that Tom in
which it didn't happen because of the
timing sure and that's to Joe's point
because it then makes it truly
appropriated money and not new money
that's right I just want to make sure
that we're not dragging it down the road
now if the 100,000 need to be put in an
additional 100,000 because you're taking
it out if the number is 400 and we don't
know what the number to build that
building
is assume we probably know that better
for next year that's exactly right I
just want Council to understand that
that's how it all came about and that's
why the source for that particular
funding of the overtime was selected and
we talked about that in the Safety
Committee we did at length so it wasn't
surprised to the committee um I heard a
rumor that uh councilman alers will not
be here today so you want to that right
I mean this this is going on for two
readings so this is coming up for no but
I mean for him to okay yeah I know
whether you want to put another person
in there beside him um I mean Becky do
you want to be my second in the event
that comes to that he's not I think
he'll be here okay that's all right
you're good and two readings yes okay
thank thank you Mr chair um next item is
temporary resolution
885-2480
one to fund the city's annual
contribution to Fairfield County Dog
Shelter and I would like to call an
aitor Nettles to explain that perhaps um
this is monies that um were forgotten
during the budget process that um for
the to for the city to pay for the
services at the fful County Dog
Shelter so any
questions and we are looking at uh three
readings and uh Council ALS you my
second temporary resolution 86- 4 a
resolution to authorize the service
safety director to advertise for bids
and enter into a contract for the
construction of the booving Road South
Broad Street and Hamburg Road
Improvement program hyphen Paving
project this is coming from uh Public
Works committee and councilman Tiner yes
um this regarding the uh booving road
we've discussed it thoroughly in
committee U I'm going to have um Kurt
explain it and then you might as well
just stay at the podium for the next two
after that if you can so this is the uh
next STP project that we have
programed it is um boing
Road and a little piece of South Broad
Street and Hamburg Road beyond the
split um we're actually getting started
today with South Broad Street a
different project uh we're just calling
this one booving road this is um federal
dollars that are allocated ated for this
it's usually an 8020 split uh what we're
asking for is uh to go out to bid and
enter into a contract for this project
it's currently in design uh design is is
uh wrapping up we will bid this uh
hopefully in January of next
year are there any and that's just a
resurfacing
project um not a real uh complicated
project but desperately needed on
booving
Road and Mr lenberg will be my second on
that one and three readings yes please
sorry thank you next item is temporary
resolution 887-2440
again come from public works and
councilman tener yes this is regarding
by the high school if her would like to
so um the new Lancaster High School is
scheduled to open in the fall of
2026 um we are working with the schools
u in a Cooperative effort
to uh fix and U provide turn lanes for
the school with a joint
project um we're trying to put together
all the the funding to make this happen
so we'll have Arbor Valley from Fair up
to 37 will be
resurfaced uh we're also doing some some
curb work this um opwc Grant we feel is
going to be a great way to it's going to
be a good project for that we feel like
we'll get we'll get a good chance of
getting that Grant uh that will fund you
know approximately 25% of the
project if we can get this grant so what
we're asking for now is uh permission to
apply for that Grant it's usually due in
the 1 of November so we get this
legislation we'll get to work on the
writing the grant uh to go after this
money question when do you hope to have
this project done
though everything goes right we would
like to do the at least the leg going up
the hill to 37 uh done before the school
opens and then we would either do the
the leg going south to Fair
Avenue that same year or maybe the
following year the problem is we have a
very little window to do that size of a
project if we tell the contractor you
know you can only do that when school's
out during the summer then uh we're
going to get really high bids or no bids
uh so we're trying to probably stretch
that that out into a year two-year
project and then hope that it gets done
you know it's all it's all done before
school opens thank
you and Mrs kites is my uh Second and
three readings thank you question uh c
um is there a match requirement of the
this particular
Grant there is a match requirement um we
will only ask for you know5 or $600,000
because we know that you can't ask for
much more than that or you won't get
awarded so we're going to be well over I
think it's a
206% minimum match there there are
different matches that you can apply for
but we'll be and as I said this will be
25% of the total project so we'll the
the rest of the money um we're kind of
putting that together we are going to
put three mil money into this because
the roads do need paved as they sit
right now
um so that'll pay for the in my mind
that pays for the asphalt the opwc money
pays for the curb because we don't have
a curb fund to to speak of um we're
working with the schools to get them to
to pitch in to help with the widening
where there might be a turn lane and
then um also we're looking at doing some
sidewalks and and spots and some storm
sewers so we we have the Cadillac right
now and if we can pay for it all we will
you know build it all if we can't we'll
start trimming things out of the package
no and I I appreciate that and and I
don't remember when the transition was
last year's Council or this year's
Council there was some discussion when
we apply for Grants if there is need to
determine if there's a match or not and
how much that matches and the source of
funding for those matches so what I'm
hearing is 26% match and it's a three
coming from the three Mill
of well it would be more than that it
would be um probably 50% of the pro we
we estimate it right now and these are
really rough numbers the reason I didn't
put them into legislation but you know
it's a it's a $2 million project
probably a million dollars of that will
be uh resurfacing in the asphalt 500,000
in the curb $500,000 in the uh storm
sewers but that's fine the point is uh
we got into trouble and sometime back of
applying for Grants not aware that there
was a match and all of a sudden we get
to Grant where's the match money coming
from so we kind of want to have that
kind of laid out up front so okay you
answer the question I appreciate all
right thank you any other
questions uh moving on to to Temporary
res resolution 888-246-3752
[Music]
you want to go okay so this project is
our uh we we were awarded a $2 million
Grant um through the Ohio Department of
Transportation uh they called a systemic
safety program so um it's primarily
sidewalks uh out on East Main
Street we are early in the process we
anticipate that this project will
require the acquisition of
righto which is a lengthy and expensive
process so it's it's the reason the
design fees and the Professional
Services fees are um higher than you
would expect for sidewalk
project we are going to do the design
inhouse so to to help reduce that also
to give us more flexibility in the
actual design of it so so we can kind of
keep an eye on the cost as we design
these
sidewalks what we're asking for uh today
is the $90,000 which would be the match
money for surveying and and whatever
consultant Services we might need to
need to hire RightWay acquisition and
survey or two that come to mind uh so
this would would uh get us through that
design phase and then when we get closer
to construction we you know we'll come
back or right away acquisition we'll
come back to council with the
appropriate
requests question about and you've got
second your I have a question so are
this both sides of the sidewalks or both
sides of the street there and from where
to where all the way to the court line
the project limits of the um Ying Street
out to the Community Action the signal
there at uh you know Tractor Supply
right there at that intersection so it's
uing to that
intersection okay all right so that's
the site that's kind of missing most of
them right most of the but it stops
there right yeah it on the on the north
side of Main Street I think you get to
about McDonald's and there's nothing
right on the south side I think it's a
little bit further than that um we were
looking at the whole
Corridor um that's why we're doing the
in-house design cuz maybe we don't have
to do parts of it we actually asked for
$3 million
and we wanted to include a widening of
Main Street because if you drive through
there always kind of bouncing off the
curbs so we wanted to push those curves
out a little bit but the uh powers that
be at OD do didn't want to give us that
extra million dollars for that work so
that'll be a marked improvement though
seriously sidewalks there that's great
yeah yeah it's a good project and it's
it's it's desperately needed if you
drive through there it's it's a little
bit scary
so I have a question I I'm a little
confused so this might be a dumb
question but you say you're doing the
design
inhouse but we're requesting
$888,000 for a design
contract what I I don't follow that that
thinking well the surveying we went out
and got a quote for surveying and it was
by itself was
$160,000 I believe
and that's not any of the right of way
acquisition I think they're 40 or 50
Parcels MH and to pay for acquisition
Services you're looking at $10,000 a
parcel okay it's it's just so when you
say design contract you're talking about
a consultant outside of that that's
doing your surveying and assisting in
the in the purchasing of the various
properties yeah yeah then you guys are
going to design the sidewalk layout yeah
we'll do the construction drawings okay
pull in the survey do the construction
drawings and then we'll have to have
Consultants uh we don't do that and
don't don't don't have that capability
gotta more time
thanks good question other
questions and your second uh councilman
lenberg and readings oh three readings
I'm sorry thank
you good next item is uh temporary
resolution 89 d24 a resolution to
authorize the service safety director to
enter into an engineering agreement for
construction Administration and
inspection services for the East Main
Street sewer separation and and and
Court drainage Improvement phase one
project uh coming from water water
pollution control councilman way yes
thank you Mr chairman uh both of these
two pieces um are for the East Main
Street sewer separation and and Court um
storm sewer gr confence we've talked a
little bit about that in previous
Council meetings early this year uh this
first part is for the engineering
agreement and like to turn over to
stepen to talk about the project a
little more yeah thank you um so I've
been here uh before you before um we
started design on this project um as
noted there there's kind of two areas of
East Main Street that's Encompass that
this project is encompassing the first
part the sewer separation uh portion
we're going to be in the area of angle
Street uh Cherry Street East Eastwood
Avenue to put in a new storm sewer to
take out uh some catch basins that
currently go into combined sewer um and
contribute to overflows in the um
hacking River Baldwin run specifically
in this case during rain events uh and
then the ANC Court range improvements
phase one project we're going to be
building a new storm sewer on canaa Road
and East Main Street there in East Side
in a similar area where Kurt just talked
about sidewalks are planning to go uh
and we're going to be um doing that to
try to mitigate um flooding pond that
occurs at the two catch basins on ANC
Court uh there on the east side and um
we're nearing completion of design on
this project so for this uh piece right
here we're just looking ahead to
construction we will need to we'll look
to have our engineering consultant um
assist us with construction
Administration and inspection services
and this is just asking for
authorization to uh enter into that
contract once we get to that
point any
questions three readings efficient yep
absolutely okay and councilman alss will
be my second yes
okay uh temporary resolution
90-24 uh resolution to authorize service
safety director to advertise for bids
and enter into a contract to construct
the East Main Street sewer separation
and and Court drainage Improvement phase
one project again come from water water
P Pollution
Control uh councilman way yes uh thank
you Mr chairman uh this just allows the
uh SSD to go out to bid for the project
I don't think there's anything else to
add yeah and and obviously ENT into a
contract once we publicly bid that
project we're looking to have that bid
in late October and hopefully sign
contracts by
December any
questions all right Council tin Tina
will be my second and we'll go three
readings three readings thank you thank
you temporary resolution
9124 a resolution to increase seats in
fund 8058 Violet Township city of
Lancaster Jed amend the certificate of
other sources with County auditor and
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and amend the certificate
Appropriations with the county auditor
in the Violet Township city of Lancaster
Jed 8058 and income tax fund
26 that's a lot isn't it
yes um the Jed part is basically we
didn't know what we didn't know when we
went into the agreement of what was
going to be collected so being halfway
into the year we kind of have a good
idea right now the only um entity that
we're collecting on is um Violet
Township themselves that are physically
at The Wigwam so this is just um
increasing receipts and expense by the
same amount to to go to us for our
percentage for collection and then
theirs for the remainder so that's the
first part for the Jed and then the
refund is um I'm just adding a cushion
um I'm not sure how we're going to end
as with collections increase so do
refunds um businesses are now allowed to
have an extension as of some legislation
that was passed last year by the state
until
November um for their net profit so I
just didn't want to be in a bind come
November when in the midst of BU
budgeting and all the other craziness
that's going on so what doesn't get used
obviously goes back into my cash and I'm
pulling for my cash balance right now to
to fund that expense line item so
questions real quick question how's
income tax collections running this year
per the initial budget I know it's half
year but still we're we're we're looking
good we're over over budget I would say
and I'm just a little bit short of where
we were last year but I think if you've
looked at my emails you know there's a
lot of timing differences August for us
is a three pay three pay month so
different businesses have different
times that some of those um deposits hit
us differently so um we're doing we're
doing well so so I can
continue he's not here okay thank you no
other questions um the second will be uh
councilman aers and we'll do three
readings sufficient for you works for me
good thank you very
much moving on to Temporary resolution
[Music]
uh councilman lenberg first of three
readings and I've asked Mark to address
it yeah this is to uh apply like you
said for two grants to the Ohio cyber
Ohio um program the first is a.gov
migration Grant and basically what that
means is they want us to register a.gov
domain and start using that for our
website and all our emails um
and uh I've already registered the name
Lancaster
ohio.gov um so that is available and is
ours at the moment um and this covers
all the cost involved in setting up that
domain name switching the website over
switching the emails over um it goes all
the way down to you can get new business
cards letter heads printed um so we're
trying to go through the process now to
find out all What expenses it'll cover
and what we need to apply for for that
one um the second one is a more General
grant for any type of cyber security or
Services uh that you could use in your
department uh as most of you are aware
one of the big things we already
currently use is for our multiactor
authentication software we use Cisco uh
Duo program and we pay per user per year
for that this grant can cover that cost
and then it also includes other types of
cyber security software that we could
apply for and also any type of
additional training so again we're
through to see all what we want to apply
for uh on that
side okay any
questions say just playing for Grants
would you like us to go ahead if to
suspend to get it in sooner rather than
later to because it's good to get it in
so they that's up up to your pleasure it
doesn't matter I know we're going to
have at least um I would estimate three
or four more weeks of putting together
our actual Grant
application um because of all the
details we have to put in there and we
have until the middle September to
actually uh get the application up to
the state so we have enough time for
three readings if you want to do
it so we'll put in three readings and if
you see a time change uh we'll have the
next second reading of the 26th of
August so let us know if you're get in a
bind um and your
second uh that would be Joe yep okay and
we talked about the readings you're okay
with that yeah I Mark about
that next item uh temporary resolution
993-2807
law committee
and councilman crates thank you um this
is for the municipal Court's probation
Department's drug testing equipment
whose contract is getting ready to
expire and Tam btek is here to speak to
that thank you ma'am yes our contract
for our drug testing reagents is getting
ready to expire um we've had this U
several contracts over the last 10 years
that we've been with this company uh the
issue is that with this company it is
also integrated with our drug testing
case management system uh there are
several agencies including the city of
Lancaster HR department um Fairfield
County HR department Children's Services
Domestic Relations Court as well as
municipal court and Common Police Court
that relies on this case management
software uh that's only available
through this company so we have 10 years
of drug testing information and data on
individuals in the this system and if we
switch over to a new company we will
lose that data so it's vitally important
that we stay with this company um in
order to have a seamless transition of
case management
software thank you and you're going to
be my second I'll be honored to be your
second and your three readings is fine
and as I understand this money is
already in your budget in that's correct
yes thank you it's always good and we
have to find money no nope money is
already there right thank you very much
thank you temporary resolution
resolution
9424 resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement with the designed
professionals at schoie Caldwell for the
city hall Rehabilitation project coming
again from the law committee and the
councilman CH yes uh service safety
director Wy would you mind speaking to
this absolutely thank you so I think uh
you are aware that we had a contract
with fly called well they are the ones
that won the bid process back in 2020 to
evaluate City Hall um and put together a
very nice uh document for city council
and the city Administration back in 2020
on everything that needed to be fixed in
our city hall building at 104 East Main
Street um because of timing and funding
we weren't able to get that project
started but we are now in the process
where we would like to at least start
renovating the exterior of City Hall um
but when we got ready to do that we
realized that we had an expired contract
um in addition to that because we are
scaling the project originally it was
going to be close to $4 million project
so the contract had uh recommended a
construction manager at risk however
since we are going to again make this
project a much smaller scale and just do
the exterior um it's going to be a much
uh cheaper project for us um we're
looking at probably four 4 and A5
million for the project we're going to
do the exterior but we also need to
replace our elevator in city hall
because it keeps breaking down and
people are getting stuck in
it like uh councilman
KES uh so we do need to do that as well
so it's looking like it's going to be
about 4.5 million um but because it is a
much smaller scale project now uh
schoolie Caldwell recommended that we
just have someone locally kind of manage
the project and not do a construction
manager at risk so because we want need
to uh update the contract in terms of
timing um talking with uh law director
Hall we also needed to update the
language in the contract um which is why
we had this before you today and I'll
ask if direct uh law director Hall has
anything else to add no you covered it
all
perfectly and Mr bisj will be my second
and we'll go two readings two readings
any other questions thank thank
you temporary resolution 94 or not
excuse me 95-2 4 a resolution to
authorize the service safety director to
advertise for bids and enter enter into
a contract for the city hall renovation
project again coming from law committee
councilman crates yes thank you uh this
piece of legislation legislation just
allows the service safety director to go
out for bids on that renovation project
she was just discussing
than did you have anything else you
wanted to add and I will I do not thank
you you're
welcome and this will be yourself as my
second and we'll go two readings two
readings again any other questions on
that that takes care of the resolutions
for tonight uh we have two ordinances um
the first ordinance is temporary
ordinance
26-24 an ordinance to amend uh permanent
ordinance 34-2
23 uh the management pay ordinance and
to declare an emergency coming from
finance
committee and
um I'm not sure who's going to serice
safety director are you going to talk
about this certainly thank you uh thank
you uh chair wolfinger so our
um our position had previously been
named an executive director and that was
the position that Linda Bergie disser
had held um it had been named an
executive director for many many years
Mary Joe prior to her was also named the
executive director however when we've
looked at all of the other job titles
throughout the city it doesn't really
match the rest of the job titles from
other departments so we wanted to go
ahead and take this opportunity to
rename the title to make it more in line
with other job titles throughout the
city um in addition we also were looking
at pay ranges throughout other
management throughout the city so comp
to um like in L do the um the operations
manager in L do operations manager in
water water pollution gas uh so we
wanted to bring that pay down in line
with those other managers that are
similar um at the same time we are
looking at doing some reorganization
throughout the city something that uh
mayor and I have heard uh since January
is um needing support uh for our
planning department our zoning
department
um a couple other departments so we
thought this would be a great time for
us to take the opportunity to maybe
restructure so that we can kind of share
the resources that we already have so
our Community Development Department we
are reorganizing to include not only the
housing program that Linda berie disser
had been doing with the block grant the
chip Grant um but also including in
Community Development our building our
planning and our zoning to make it all
one big department so that they can
function a little bit better share some
of the resources they have like
Administrative Assistant the permit
clerk we have um an inspector plus a
contracted inspector in the Community
Development Department already plus we
have inspectors in the building
department they're relying on each other
almost daily to help each other with
different projects so we thought by
combining all of these departments then
they can help share resources rather
than trying to add additional resources
um but in the process uh we are asking
to raise the city planners uh pay from
an 18 to a 21 to oversee all of those
departments as one whole department now
I know that's a lot and I'm going to
apologize publicly to all of my
department heads because I keep
reminding them to ask for three readings
at all times but I'm the problem child
asking for suspension if possible
tonight so that I can post um the vacant
position that Linda Bergie disser uh is
has uh given us since she her last day
was actually this past
Friday I'm sure people have questions do
have a question so you're raising that
person the planner three steps up
correct but yet you got a construction
supervisor in the water department
that's going from a 19 to an 18 now
that's well the construction supervisor
is number three in management for
water so your your department head in
water is making a lot more more than
that the second person the second
manager in water is at a
range oh I'm trying to remember I don't
have it in front of me um I want to say
they're at a range 21 maybe um and then
the construction supervisor would be the
third level man 28 plant manager 21
construction supervisor going from a 19
to an 18 distribution manager 21 and
compliance manager 18 correct and again
we're just trying
to be a little more consistent across
the board so looking if you look at like
L Do's pay structure you have your
superintendent your operations manager
is at the
uh is at like the 21 and then the the
next two level managers which would be
similar to the construction manager at
water is at a range 18 okay so the
person that is now the city planner did
they go to school for City Planning in
that because I remember back a couple
years ago when they hired the the lady
to do that we were we were told we were
going to hire somebody out of college
that had city planner experience from
college and then we ended up hiring
mayor sheffer's secretary and she pieced
out so now we have somebody from
transportation that moved over but does
she have education for planning so I'll
answer this in two fold
okay um when we posted this position and
and again no offense to chasn Carter
when we uh posted this position uh we
were trying to get someone with an
actual planning degree we made three
offers to people with an actual planning
degree and all three declined because
they took jobs in bigger cities with
bigger with larger pay um chasn had
interviewed as well for the position she
does not have an actual planning degree
but she does have two other degrees a
bachelor's and a master's and then she
does have a lot of planning background
from the public transit she had to be
very heavily involved in all of the
transit development planning um they had
to do 10year and 20-year plans and she
did a lot
of education classes through OD do that
were offered and through morsy on on
planning so she doesn't have a planning
degree but she does have a planning
background and she has taken a lot of
classes on planning okay so I know
that's a long-winded two-part answer but
that's fine thank you just so you know
we weren't just trying to promote
someone to promote someone we did
actively search for um a city planner
and I know CT if he's still in the
audience he was with us we did panel
interviews um so we did try and find
someone with a planning degree but we
just couldn't get anyone local okay
that's fine yep thank you I have a
question when is the next cdbg Grant do
application do we just signed that and
just authorized that and I believe
that's a two-year
cycle or one year so in another year I'm
looking at Kelly Frank cuz she's the
brains of the
operation she knows cdbg inside and out
so yeah it'll be another year
okay Mr chairman if I could I just
wanted to add and remind uh Council of
our discussion when the city planner
position was created and about the um
the thought that we would have a
One-Stop shop to try to help people
through the planning building zoning
process this is our next step to get
there currently if you come to the city
of Lancaster and you need help you go
several places and you may be told
different answers depending on what that
person's particular job is building
zoning planning engineering and by
having this brought into the community
what will be the new Community
Development Department all working
together in the same area communication
should be better that One-Stop shop
Vision that mayor Sheffer told us that
he had we believe we can achieve most of
that we still can't house Engineering in
the same building because we don't have
enough space but this is a major step in
the right direction I believe and I
think uh the community will benefit from
this and I think you'll see that this is
a a
streamlining of the
operations not not an
expansion so that's my two cents worth
please and if I could just also address
the reason I'm asking for suspension I
know that I I kind of addressed that
earlier but for those of you who aren't
aware aware uh Kelly Frank is our acting
uh director right now for Community
Development however Kelly is also
retiring in November she's already given
me her date and seems very excited even
though I begged her to stay um but
because she is retiring and she is a
wealth of knowledge I am trying to get
someone in here as soon as possible to
learn as much as they can from Kelly
before she retires in November
and not to beat a dead horse uh the
transit when we had Transit the
supervisor position that was a grade 21
21 MH so she was at a 21 that she took a
three grade drop into a planning
position now she's picking up three
other departments so and that 21 is
consistent with the other like you
mentioned OT and other Departments of
the number two person of the number two
yes correct better consistency in the
grading correct fine thank you thank you
very much other
questions um are there any issues with
suspension tonight I know it's a lot to
digest but uh um hearing none uh we'll
move towards suspension and councilman
scoob would you be willing to Second t
for me thank you finally we've got
temporary ordinance 27-25 for uh an
ordinance to accept the final plat for
timbertop subdivision coming from go
code and
Zoning uh actually that's uh councilman
alers is someone going to speak for
that I can so thank you yep no problem
chairman um so the July Planning
Commission meeting um the timbertop
subdivision um came before Planning
Commission and requested that the city
accept the final plat as it had uh
created it at that time and the
administration asked that um engineering
and um the city planner and everybody
worked together in order to try and help
that happen because Vision development
who developed the bend already right up
front um also wants to develop another
portion of the timbertop subdivision
into um market rate uh multif family
residential housing and in order to um
fulfill their contract with the
developer lemon development um and have
everything kind of lined up timing wise
they needed to keep this moving through
the process and so the um Planning
Commission went ahead and they heard the
case and they looked at the plat and
they accepted the recommendations of the
engineering department which were to
accept the final plat um conditionally
based on there were three or four
different things that still needed to be
done at that point and so Kurt Sean is
um kind of actively managing that
process to make sure that they are going
to meet those those requirements and if
they fail to meet those requirements
then we will just table this until which
time they actually do meet the
requirements or you know ultimately it
can be can be removed allog together if
if necessary
yeah and I can give some updates on that
thanks at the time there were some
questions about easements and sanitary
sewer and water line extensions that
were shown on the preliminary plot but
it wasn't clear whether they were needed
in this phase of the
development um we've been working
through that since then because this was
back July 11th was Planning Commission
so you know fast forward a month we know
that those extensions that we we're in
question we know that they're not
happening they are doing one water line
extension so the the conditions of the
plat we're we're working towards that
and we've asked that they um have all
the comments addressed and everything
you know zipped up and submitted to the
city one week prior to the final reading
whenever that is so if it doesn't happen
you know we just keep pushing it out so
um I'm confident that it will happen
there there aren't a lot of issues
remaining
so questions y questions from anybody
additional
questions and we're
uh president's not here so we're looking
at three readings and U you'll be the L
be
second that concludes the
ordinances um other discussion items
departmental updates
good evening everyone just wanted to
have a couple items for this evening uh
first want to give an update on the
construction of new transfer station not
sure who's drove by took a look um it's
really looking like a complete building
we're working on some fill um and then
going to be moving into the asphalt and
uh all the concrete work is done but the
fill and and getting it up to grade
around the whole structure which is is a
going to be a interesting uh procedure
with us still operating the other
transfer stations they're trying to do
all that so we we are delayed we were
looking at hopefully at the end of
August that they were going to be
completely done with that um we've had
some door delays a fan different just
kind of silly things that pop up when
you have a project like this so they're
looking at the end of September to be
completed with it all the pavement done
um everything on the ground ready to go
and then we have to go through our
process with the Ohio EPA in regards to
getting the the authorization to operate
it so um we have a somebody right now
that's working on all of the couple 100
page uh report that goes to them in
regards to we build everything as we
said we're going to build it in the
initial permit and then we hopefully
getting an idea from them that they
don't think it's going to take more any
more than a couple days for to turn that
around and I would be shocked but that
would be great if that's the case so uh
that was a number one item second item I
had called uh Larry Al's councilman El
this morning I had received a call um we
have the legislation um
75-24 it's for that frontload garbage
truck um for some additional funding
that I needed for that originally I
thought that truck was not going to be
on the ground here until November um
they actually called as me if I wanted
it delivered Thursday so with that being
said obviously we could really use the
truck so if if at you know at your
pleasure if you find so that we could do
that that would be great we can get it
get it delivered um because I have you
know po open it's just this is the gap
funding as we talked about and and then
on the flip side I've sold the side load
to to generate that Revenue that's there
and I'm going to be selling another
front load which will also you know take
me up above I imagine that front load
will probably sell for 100 150,000 just
with the way the uh pricing is on trucks
so I was kind of shocked when they
called and said it was was here in Grove
City and asked if I wanted it Thursday
so I said well I will call you
tomorrow so anybody have any questions
on
that no questions thank you for the uh
Sean for
thek I'll be asking for suspension
I kind of figured that yeah thank
you um
Chief I just have a quick update are we
still doing updates absolutely we know
we're at seven and why do we go to eight
okay it'll be quick I just I just wanted
to say that uh the property 1590 East
Main Street that we've talked about for
a couple months uh which started as just
so we could build that uh building that
we I was talking about earlier uh we
closed on that this morning at 10
o'clock um I just sat there and and
watched the mayor signed paperwork for a
half an hour uh but good news is is that
the city now owns it um we will get
possession as soon as uh pdhc completes
the buildout of their their new place um
in the short term we're using that for
again the the maintenance building
that's going to go out in the field out
back and since we have several years
before we can build a new engine house
on that footprint uh we're going to use
take advantage of the house uh on the
property for training and maybe a little
storage but um training for us and we're
going to involve the get the police
department involved and have they can
use that for training as well so I just
want to say thank everybody for your
support with getting uh this project
done thank you thank you any questions I
think we've talked a lot about not
walking away before well we know where
to find you
excuse
me okay I believe the service safety
director would like to have uh I just
wanted one more update uh Steve gayfield
wanted to be here this evening to give
everyone an update on the bridge and
pickle ball courts I don't want to steal
that Thunder from him uh so he will be
at the next meeting to give you an
official update um but in the meantime
he did want to let you know that he is
going to be working on putting together
ribbon cutting with a photo op in
September uh so when he gets that put
together he will send out an email and
an invitation to all the council oh
boy thank you very
much tonight's meeting pro thank you
chair wolfinger tonight we have 23
resolutions many of which we have heard
already this evening in addition to four
ordinances uh sitting next to me tonight
on my right is a Anitra Scott assistant
auditor who is um going to be acting
clerk for purposes of this meeting so
I'd like everybody to give her a warm
Round of Applause and welcome so thank
you for stepping in and um to my left is
our um oldest newest how should I put
that how how do I put that returning
council member um um council member
kites so we're happy to have her back in
that role so thank you
and that's all thank you other items for
finance
committee I'm looking for a motion to
adjourn so
move all those in favor please signy by
saying I I we are adjourned and it is
659 regular regular meeting of Lancaster
City city council will convene promptly
at uh
7:05 hello I'm Ken Culver with the
Lancaster Playhouse Lancaster Playhouse
is dedicated to the theater arts and
strives to create an experience that
will entertain Inspire and challenge our
audiences actors and volunteers as a
nonprofit We really count on local
support that's why we are once again so
excited to be chosen as one of the
Buckeye car's recipients this month
Buckeye will make a generous donation
with every car they sell and we couldn't
be more grateful thank you Buckeye for
your
support the Frankie Smith Funeral Home
in cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
0652 stop in and see us at either of our
two locations 405 North Columbus Street
in Lancaster and 207 South Main Street
in Baltimore respect for tradition
regard for change
[Music]
e
e e
okay if you please join me in a moment
of Prayer
God grant us the serenity to accept the
things we cannot change the courage to
change the things we can and finally the
wisdom to know the
difference I now call the August 12th
2024 Lancaster City council meeting to
order please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all would the acting clerk please call
the role Mr
aers miss Mr ALS here Mr bizjack here M
Mrs CES here Mrs hoop here Mrs lenberg
Mr lenberg here Mr skover here miss
Tiner here Mr Wing here and Mr Waker
here let the record reflect that nine
members of city council are present and
I would ask do we have a motion to
excuse council member aers I would make
that motion second we have a motion and
a second to excuse council member aers
please uh signify U by saying I uh your
approval I I those opposed same
sign thank you we'll now move to the
reading and disposal of the
journal uh regular meetings dated July
2024 Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that we
yep approve or yeah I lost it
that's so receive and file the journal
sorry thanks second we have a motion and
second to receive and file the journal
all those in favor please signify by
saying I I all those oppose same
sign do we have any reports of City
officials um email data July 15 2024
regarding the code and zoning committee
minutes submitted by Mr
aers email data July 15 2024 regarding
the finance committee minute sub
submitted by Mr
wolfinger email dated July 17 2024
regarding the Miller Park concept
submitted by superintendent gayfield
email datea July 17 2024 regarding the
2024 June revenue report submitted by
Tax Commissioner
Hamilton email dated July 22nd 2024
regarding the poll's restroom policy
submitted by Miss tener email dated July
22nd 2024 regarding the economic
development committee agenda as
submitted by Mrs hoop
email dat of July 23rd 2024 regarding
the linkster foldable housing
presentation submitted by director
Bergie
diser email date of July 23rd 2024
regarding the water poll and water water
pollution control committee agenda um
submitted by Mr
Wing email datea July 31st 2024
regarding the economic development
committee minute sub submitted by Mrs
hoop
email dated July 31st 2024 regarding the
sa Safety Committee agenda submitted by
Mr
bisj email dated August 1st 2024
regarding the water water pollution
control committee minutes submitted by
Mr
Wing email dated August 5th 2024
regarding the July 2024 collection
report submitted by Tax Commissioner
Hamilton series of emails dated August
4th 2024 regarding the public works
committee agenda in October meeting
submitted by Miss tener Mr skover and
superintendent
Deets email dated August 8th 2024
regarding the UPC upcoming code and
zoning committee meeting submitted by Mr
aers email dated August 9th 2024
regarding rescheduling the October
Public Works committee meeting submitted
by Miss
tener email dated August 9th 201 24
regarding the Safety Committee minutes
submitted by Mr bis Jack email dated
August 9th 2024 regarding the finance
committee agenda submitted by Mr
wolfinger Mr President i' like to make a
motion to receive and F the reports of
City officials second we have a motion a
second to receive and file the reports
of City officials all those in favor
please signify by saying
I all those oppose same sign do we have
any
Communications um email data July 17
2024 regarding an information request
submitted by
Anna would yeah
um I'm that last name
would wosik wosik of laella
Associates thank you email dat data July
30th 2024 regarding the August 5th law
committee meeting submitted by Timothy
Keel email dated August 7 2024 regarding
the information requested submitted by
Timothy
ke email dated August 10 2024 regarding
mosquito spraying submitted by James
Barker Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the
communications second we have a motion
and second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
signify by saying an i all those oppose
same sign and let the record reflect my
pronunciation of that last name may not
be
correct uh do we have any special
presentations there are none are there
any petitions or memorials this evening
there are none this time we set as aside
time for voters and taxpayers to address
Council are there any individuals here
this evening that would like to address
Council seeing none we thank you for
coming to this evening's meeting are
there any standing committee reports
Public Works committee minutes dated
June 14 2024 submitted by Miss
tener code and zoning committee minutes
dated June 21st 2024 submitted by Mr
aers finance committee minutes dated
July 15 2024 submitted by Mr
wolfinger Economic Development Committee
minutes dated July 25th 2024 subed
submitted by Mrs hoop water water
pollution control committee minutes
dated July 26 2024 submitted by Mr Wing
and Safety Committee minutes dated
August 2nd 2024 submitted by Mr
bisj Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and follow the reports
of standing committees second have a
motion and second to receive and file
the reports of standing committees all
those in favor please signify by saying
I I all those oppose same sign are there
any reports of special committees this
evening there are none okay there are no
public hearings this evening we will now
move on to the reading of
resolutions starting with temporary
resolution
6724 a resolution to reduce your
preparations from the Municipal Court
special project fund 2037 and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with this
County Auditor
um by finance committee um Mr wolfinger
and Mr
skover council member wolfinger thank
you Mr President I would like to make a
motion that Council pass Andross and
enter on the written record resolution
temporary resolution 67 d24 second we
have a motion and a second to pass
Andross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 67 24 any
discussion council member wolfinger uh
thank you Mr President this this is a an
entry that's really going to move money
from one account to another account in
the Municipal Court area uh in a total
of
$120,000 thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
rle Mr Al oh
sorry Mr ALS yes M Mr bisj yes Mrs CH
yes Mrs Hoops yes Mr L lenberg yes Mr
skun yes Miss tener yes Mr wol Wing yes
Mr wolfinger yes temporary resolution
passes 9 to0 now move to Temporary
resolution
7024 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to advertise for
bids for the uing Run manhole
reconstruction
project uh water water pollution Mr Wing
and Mr alss council member Wing uh thank
you Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolu resolution
7024 second we have a motion and second
to pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
7024 any discussion council member Wing
uh simple piece just to fix part of
youing run that currently flows over
manhole further
discussion hearing none please call the
RO Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr schover
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution 7024
passes 9 to0 temporary resolution
7224 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
engineering agreement for Engineering
Services for the construction of the
southwater plant booster pump project
water water pollution uh Mr Wing and Mr
ALS council member Wing thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
7224 second we have a motion and second
to pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
7224 council member Wing any discussion
this is just a routine piece that we
have to pass for Engineering Services
thank you any further discussion hearing
none please call the role Mr alss yes Mr
bisj yes Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener yes
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
temporary resolution
7224 passes 9 to Z temporary resolution
7324 a resolution to authorize the
auditor to complete 2024 budget
transfers as needed to complete the
public transit fund 2021 transition to
the fairfeld county
um Finance Mr wolfinger and Mr skover
council member wolfinger thank you Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council pass engross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
73-20 second we have a motion in a
second to pass and gross an enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
7324 council member wolfinger any
discussion uh this is moving and
establishing accounts to
set aside funds that will take care of
the payment of the uh City's former
responsibility of the uh uh Transit uh
Department any further
discussion hearing none please call the
rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs KES
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes temporary
resolution 7324 passes 9
to0 we'll now move on to Second reading
of resolutions beginning with temporary
resolution
7524 a resolution to appropriate from
the UN incomer balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor and the sanitation fund
60005 for the purchase of a new
frontload garbage truck um service and
Mr alss and Mr hoop council member alss
uh yes Mr President I'd like to move
that we suspend council's rules and wave
the third reading of resolution
temporarily number
75-24 second we have a motion second to
wave the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary resolution
7524 uh discussion council member ALS no
okay hearing no further discussion we'll
move um to call the RO on the motion to
suspend Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CH
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes motion to suspend
rules and wave the third reading of
temporary resolution 7524 passes 9 to Z
council member alss uh yes Mr President
I'd like to move that we uh that Council
pass and engross and enter upon the
written record resolution temporarily
number 75-24
second we have a second motion and a
second to pass Andress and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
7524 any further discussion council
member
Al um this was budgeted um he just it
came in early he wants to he wants to
put it in use
so thank you any further
discussion please call the RO Mr alss
yes Mr Bishop yes Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes M tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
motion to pass uh temporary resolution
7524 passes 9 to Zer moving on to
Temporary resolution
7624 a resolution to accept the
recommendation of the tax incentive
review Council for the continuance of
the 20 2006 80 road tax
increment financing agreement the 2023
timbertop tax increment financing
agreement in the Lancaster Community
reinvestment areas pursuant to Ohio RIS
Co
5 C1 and e finance committee fin Mr
wolfinger Mr arol council member
wolfinger this will be the second of
three readings second of three readings
on temporary resolution
7624 temporary resolution
7824 um a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
agreement for Engineering Services for
the design and bidding of replacement
pressure filter valves at the South
water plant treatment plant um water
water pollution
um pollution control committee um Mr
Wing and Miss tener council member Wing
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council suspend its rules
and wave the third reading of uh
resolution temporarily numbered
7824 second we have a motion and a
second to wave the rule rules and uh
wave the third reading of temporary
resolution 7824 any discussion council
member way the reason for suspension is
so that we can meet the arpit deadline
thank you any further discussion hearing
none please call the RO on the motion to
suspend Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs kites
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr
wolfinger yes to suspend the rules and
wave the third reading of temporary
resolution 7824 passes 9
to0 now move uh back to council member
Wing Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that Council pass Andross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily number to 7824
second we have a motion a second uh to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
7824 um any discussion council member I
have nothing further
hearing no further discussion please
call a rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs
crates yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes
Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes motion to pass uh
and gross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 7824 passes
9 to Z temporary resolution
7924 a resolution authorizing the
service safety director to advertise for
BS to construct the zann alley sewer
replacement project water water
pollution committee Mr Wing and Mr ALS
council member Wing thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council suspend its rules and wave the
third reading of resolution temporarily
numbered
7924 second we have a motion a second to
wave the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary resolution
7924 any discussion council member Wing
yeah thank you Mr President uh this is
another combined sewer project uh right
here downtown and the reason for
suspension is so that we can uh get
construction started during construction
season thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call a r
Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs kites yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and wave the third reading of
temporary resolution 7924 passes 9 to0
council member wing thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council pass and gr and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
7924 second we have motion a second to
pass and gross enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 7924 council
member Wing any further discussion
nothing further thank you hearing none
other discussion please call or Ro Mr
ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss
Tiner yes Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes
motion to um pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
resolution 7924 passes 9 to0 temporary
resolution 8024 a resolution authorizing
the service safety director to dispense
with competitive bidding for soul Source
providers for filter reconstruction for
the South Water Treatment Plant water
water pollution committee Mr Wing and Mr
Miss tener council member Wing thank you
Mr President I'd like to make a motion
that Council suspended rules and wave
the third reading of resolution
temporary numbered 8024 second we have a
motion a second to wave the rules and
wave the third reading for temporary
resolution
8024 uh council member W yes thank you
Mr President um this piece is also uh
facing a deadline uh to apply for arpa
funds and then just a reminder uh it
also
um signifies the same company that put
the filters in in the first place is
also uh going to redo them this time as
well
thank you any further discussion on the
motion to suspend hearing none please
call a ro Mr alss yes Mr bisj yes Mrs
cig yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mrs
Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes motion to suspend
the rules and wave the third reading of
temporary resolution 8024 passes 9
to0 council member Wing uh thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council pass and enter upon the written
record uh temporary resolution
8024 second we have a motion in a second
to pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
8024 uh discussion council member Wing
nothing further any further discussion
hearing none please call the role Mr ALS
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs kites yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes
motion to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
8024 passes 9 to Z we'll now move on to
Temporary resolution
8124 a resolution authorizing the
service safety director to wave
competitive bidding and enter into
contract for the con
or for the concentrate discharge
Improvement project and to declare an
emergency water water pollution um
control um Mr Wing and Mr alss council
member Wing thank you Mr President I'd
like to make a motion that Council
suspend its rules and we the third
reading of resolution temporarily
numbered
8124 second we have a motion in a second
to wave the rules and wave the third
reading for temporary resolution
8124 council member Wing thank you Mr
President uh this is as many of you
heard this past year probably before
this is a issue that's been been going
on for a while due to the emergent
nature of it um we're requesting
suspension
tonight any further
discussion hearing none please call the
roll on the motion to suspend Mr ALS yes
Mr bisj yes M Mrs KES Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener yes
Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes motion to
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading for temporary resolution
812 24 passes 9 to0 council member wing
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record uh
resolution number
second have a motion a second to pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution 802
8124 any discussion council member any
further thank you any further discussion
hearing none please call a roll Mr alss
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CES yes Mrs hoop yes
Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes M yes Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger
yes motion to pass Andross and enter
upon the written record temporary
resolution 8124 passes 9 to0 we'll now
move on to Temporary resolution
8324 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into
development agreement with the urban
Restorations for its project known as
the
scheuer um finance committee Mr
wolfinger or Mr ALS council member
wolfinger this will be the second of
three readings second of three readings
on temporary resolution
8324 we' have completed uh second
reading of resolutions and move on to
First reading with temporary resolution
8424 a resolution to increase and
decrease Appropriations in the police
and fire Levy fund 2047 for the
Lancaster fire department over time
Safety Committee Mr bisj and Mr alss
council member bisj thank you Mr
President pres this this will be the
first of two readings first of two
readings on temporary res resolution
8424 temporary resolution
8524 a resolution to appropriate from
the UN incomer balance and to amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor and the general fund
10001 to fund the city's annual
contribution to the fairfi County Dog
Shelter uh with finance committee Mr
wolfinger and Mr alss council member
wolfinger that'll be the first of three
readings first of three readings on
temporary resolution
8524 temporary resolution
8624 a resolution to authorize the Cy
Sav service safety director to advertise
for bids and enter in the contract for
construction of the booving Road South
Broad Street and Hamburg Road
Improvement program Paving project
Public Works committee Miss tener and Mr
lenberg council member tener first of
three readings first of three readings
on temporary resolution
8624 temporary resolution
8724 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to apply for the
grant through the Ohio Public Works
commission to fund the Arbor Valley
Drive Rehabilitation project Public
Works committee and Miss Tiner and Mrs
crates council member Tiner first of
three readings first three readings on
temporary resolution
8724 temporary resolution 8824 a
resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into a Design
preconstruction
Services contracts with various
consultants for the East Main Street
Improvement project PID number
122006 to prorate from the UN incomer
balance and to amend the certificate of
Appropriations with the county auditor
in the general fund
one01 Public Works committee Miss Tiner
and Mr lenberg council member tener also
uh first of three readings first of
three readings temporary resolution
8824 temporary resolution
8924 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
engineering agreement for construction
Administration and inspection services
for the East Main Street sewer
separation in an Court drainage
improvements phase one project water
water pollution control um committee Mr
Wing and Mr ill
council member Wing this will be the
first of three readings please first of
three readings on temporary resolution
8924 temporary resolution 9024 a
resolution to authorize the service
safety director to advertise for bids
and enter in a contract with cons or to
construct the East Main Street sewer
separation and an Court drainage
improvements phase one project water
water pollution control committee Mr
Wing and Miss tener council member Wing
first of three readings please first
three readings on temporary resolution
9024 temporary resolution 9124 a
resolution to increase funds or increase
receipts and fund 8058 Violet Township
of the Lancaster Jed amend the
certificate of the other sources with
the county auditor and appropriate from
un incomer balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the Violet Township
city of Lancaster Jed fund 8058 and in
come tax fund 2016 finance committee Mr
wolfinger Mr aers council member
wolfinger first of three readings first
of three readings on temporary
resolution
9124 temporary resolution
9224 a resolution to authorize the city
of Lancaster to apply for
a.gov domain migration Grant a cyber
security software and services Grant and
to execute contracts as required
administrative services
um committee Mr lenberg and Mr bisj
council member lenberg this will be the
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary resolution
9224 temporary resolution
9324 a resolution to authorize
dispensing the with competitive bidding
for the purchase of Regents for the
au480 drug testing analyzer at the
Municipal Court due to a sole service
provider law committee Miss K or Mrs k
Mr wolfinger council member KES thank
you this is the first of three readings
first of three readings on temporary
resolution
9324 temporary resolution
9424 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
agreement with the design professional
professionals at schoolie Codwell for
the city hall Rehabilitation project the
law committee Mrs Kites and Mr bisj
council member kites yes first of first
of two readings first of two readings on
temporary resolution
9424 temporary resolution
9524 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to advertise for
bids and enter into a contract with the
city hall renovation project law
committee and Mrs KES and Mr wolfinger
council member kites first of two
readings first of two readings on
temporary resolution
9524 we have now completed reading of
resolutions we'll now move to the
reading of ordinances there are no third
readings this evening we will move to
the second reading beginning with
temporary ordinance
2424 an ordinance to amend the zoning
map subject to passage of the annexation
of 5.66 4 plus or minus acres in
Pleasant Township and to declare an
emergency Economic Development Committee
Mrs hoop and Mr Wing council member who
yes second ofd three readings second of
three readings on temporary ordinance
2424 temporary ordinance
2524 um an ordinance to authorize the
mayor to enter into a school compens
compensation agreement for income tax
sharing between Amanda Clair Creek
School local school district and the
city of Lancaster the law committee Miss
Mrs crates and Mr bisj council member
crates second of three reading readings
second of three readings on temporary
ordinance
2524 we'll now move on to First reading
beginning with temporary ordinance
2624 in ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance 34-3 23 the management pay
ordinance to declare an emergency um
finance committee Mr wolfinger and Mr
skover council member
wolfinger thank you Mr President uh I
would like to make a motion that Council
suspends its rule R and waves of the
second and third reading of temporary
ordinance
26-24 second we have a motion and second
um to suspend the rules and wave the
second and third reading of temporary
ordinance
2624 discussion council member
wolfinger um I'll hold it thank you any
further discussion hearing none U please
call the rooll on the motion to suspend
Mr ALS yes Mr Jack yes Mrs KES yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr luberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the rovs
and wave the second and third reading of
temporary ordinance 2624 passes 9 to
zero council member wolfinger Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council pass and gross and enter on
the written record temporary ordinance
26-24 second we have a motion and second
to pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
2624 council member wol fer yes uh we
had an extensive conversation during the
finance committee regarding this
particular ordinance um there was kind
of two parts to it uh the first part is
to restructure the Community Development
Department and BR in there for other
departments under the same umbrella and
then the second portion of it is to uh
increase the grade level of the managing
person of that department from an 18 to
a
21 any further
discussion hearing none please call the
RO Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener no Mr Wing yes Mr wol
yes motion to pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 26 24 passes 8
to1 temporary ordinance
2724 an ordinance to accept the final
plat for the timbertop subvision code
subdivision code in zoning and Mr aers
and Mr Mrs
hoop council member
hoop okay look to you for this one for
first of three readings thank you first
of three readings on temporary ordinance
2724 that we've concluded our reading of
ordinances thank you acting clerk Scott
we appreciate your help um unfinished
business is there any unfinished
business from Council Members this
evening for points of
discussion hearing none new business um
in new business I would just like to
announce that there is a posting out
there for the clerk's position that is
permanent if anybody has any interest in
that position they need to submit their
resume by August 16th per the per the
posting we will now move to announcement
of scheduled meetings next regular
sessions of counil August 26th at 6:30
p.m. September 9th at 6:30 p.m. upcoming
special meetings there are none upcoming
committee meetings for the next 30 days
Finance committing August 26th at 6 pm.
City Chambers
Service uh September 6 at 8:00 a.m. City
Hall 1897 conference room Finance uh
September 9th at 6 p.m city council
chambers thank you move on to reading of
bills um MC mnco
$901 as publication of
legislation Mr President like to make a
motion to pay the bill second we have a
motion to second to pay the bill all
those in favor please signify by saying
I I all those oppose same sign we have
no executive session this evening and
therefore I would take a motion to
adjourn I would like to make that motion
we adjourn second in motion second to
adjourn all those in favor please
signify by saying I I all those oppose
same sign thank you very much for coming
please remember council members to stay
and sign your legislation before you
leave thank you got playing D ball this
year
e